serving in high office is an honor and
privilege it is also a heavy
responsibility that is true at any time
but especially when the stakes are so
high and negotiating the UK's withdraw
from the EU after 40 years and building
from the ground up a new and enduring
relationship for the good of our
children and grandchildren is a matter
of the highest consequence it touches
almost every area of our national life a
whole economy and virtually every job
the livelihoods of our fellow citizens
our integrity as a United Kingdom of
Four Nations our safety and security all
of these are at stake my approach
throughout has been to put the national
interest first not a partisan interest
and certainly not my own political
interest I do not judge harshly those of
my colleagues who seek to do the same
but who reach a different conclusion
they must do what they believe to be
right just as I do I'm sorry that
they've chosen to leave the government
and I thank them for their service but I
believe with every fiber of my being
that the course I have set out is the
right one for our country and all our
people from the very beginning I have
known what I wanted to deliver for the
British people to honor their vote in
the referendum full control of our
borders by bringing an end to the free
movement of people once and for all full
control of our money so we decide
ourselves how to spend it on priorities
like our NHS full control of our laws by
ending the jurisdiction of the European
Court of Justice in the United Kingdom
getting us out of the Common
Agricultural Policy and Common Fisheries
Policy for good that is exactly what
this agreement will deliver free
movement ended vast annual payments
stopped the jurisdiction of the ECJ over
out of the c.a.p out of the CFP this is
a brexit that delivers on the priorities
of the British people in achieving these
objectives
I'm also determined to protect the
things that are important to us protect
the hundreds of thousands of
manufacturing jobs that put food on the
tables of working families right across
the UK those jobs rely on cross-border
trade in goods with parts flowing easily
in and out of the UK allowing for
integrated supply chains this Agreement
protects that protect the close security
cooperation that helps keep us safe this
Agreement does that protect the
integrity of the United Kingdom and the
peaceful settlement in Northern Ireland
by leaving the EU as one United Kingdom
and having no hard border between
Northern Ireland and Ireland this
Agreement does that as well
yes difficult and sometimes
uncomfortable decisions have had to be
made I understand fully that there are
some who are unhappy with those
compromises but this deal delivers what
people voted for and it is in the
national interest and we can only secure
it if we unite behind the agreement
reached in cabinet yesterday if we do
not move forward with that agreement
nobody can know for sure the
consequences that will follow it would
be to take a path of deep and grave
uncertainty when the British people just
want us to get on with it they are
looking to the Conservative Party to
deliver to deliver a brexit that works
for the whole UK a strong economy that
keeps jobs safe and wages rising and
first-class public services we can rely
on an NHS there for all of us great
schools for every child and the homes
that families need that is what the
people we serve expect and that is what
we owe it to them to deliver goodness me
you normally put your hands straight up
after they hear
Noora and thank you very much Prime
Minister Lawrenceburg BBC News and it's
very clear you want to stick to your
plan isn't it the case though that
others are seeking to take that decision
out of your hands and Prime Minister is
it not the case now that you are in
office but you're not really in power
when we bring the deal back what is
going to happen now is that there will
be negotiations particularly focusing on
the future framework and filling their
details of that out and an EU council
meeting and that will then be brought
back to the House of Commons and to a
vote in the House of Commons I'm going
to do my job of getting the best deal
for Britain I'm going to do my job of
getting a deal that is in the national
interest when the vote comes before the
House of Commons MPs will be doing their
job they will need to look at that a
deal they will need to consider the vote
of the British people to leave the
European Union and our duty to deliver
on that vote and of course they will be
held to account by their constituents
for the decisions that they take Tom
thank you Prime Minister Tony you've
done for the son Prime Minister if there
is a confidence vote held in your
leadership of the Conservative Party do
you think it's in the national interest
for you to fight it and if you win by
only one vote will you carry on as Prime
Minister leadership is about taking the
right decisions not the easy ones as
Prime Minister my job is to bring back a
deal that delivers on the vote of the
British people that does that by ending
free movement all the things I raised in
my statement ending free movement
ensuring we're not sending vast annual
sums to the EU any lire any longer
ending the jurisdiction of the European
Court of Justice but also protects jobs
and protects people's livelihoods
protects our security protects the union
of the United Kingdom I believe that
this is a deal which does deliver that
which is in the national interest and am
I going to see this through yes next
question
yes do you want a microphone Prime
Minister Simon vigor from five news
surely now even you have to admit this
is not strong and stable what I think
people will see is that what I and the
government have done is being sticking
to the job of ensuring that we're
delivering for the British people that's
what we're doing we're delivering in the
British in the national interest and
look you know MPs have been debating the
best way to deliver brexit ever since
the referendum took place in 2016 and
there's been much criticism throughout
that time of the government's approach
people have been ready to point out what
they don't like but one simple fact
remains and that is that nobody has
produced any alternative proposal which
both delivers on the referendum and also
ensures that there's no hard border
between Northern Ireland and Ireland and
I understand some people feel
uncomfortable about the details in the
backstop particularly in the withdrawal
agreement and I share some of those
concerns but there's another inescapable
fact there is no deal which can be
agreed with the European Union that does
not involve a backstop to act as an
insurance policy against a return to the
borders of the past in Northern Ireland
all the other approaches Norway Canada
plus etcetera they would all require a
backstop and the alternative of
repudiating that backstop would not only
mean reneging on a promise to the people
of Northern Ireland but it would also
collapse the negotiation and het and
hopes of securing a deal so what is the
government being doing we have been
absolutely clear in focusing on
delivering what is in the best interest
of the British people faisal first islam
Sky News prime minister you're not in
denial about the chances of getting this
deal through Parliament and for the
critics in your own party there have
been sending in letters very publicly is
it time for them to put up or shut up
what I as I think you may have heard me
say in the House of Commons earlier
today is I've just reiterated here I'm
going to do my job of bringing back the
best deal for the United Kingdom that
will then be put before the House of
Commons it will be
before members of parliament in a
meaningful vote their job will be to
look at that deal their job will be to
consider the interests of their
constituents and their job will be to
consider how we can deliver on the vote
of the British people to leave the
European the European Union and I think
you know I think most people watching
this or listening to to this will
recognize that this is not an easy thing
to do this is a complex negotiation but
I think what most people want to know is
that what we will deliver will be in
their interests it will protect jobs it
will protect security it will ensure a
great future for this country yes Rob
Hutton from Bloomberg isn't it time to
to say what you clearly think which is
the the the brexit campaign offered
something that was not on the menu it
offered very very easy trade
negotiations it offered there was to be
no problem at all with the Irish border
it was all going to be fantastic
straight forward the European Union was
going to give us everything we wanted
because of BMW and Prosecco and things
like that isn't it time to say that I'm
afraid some of the things that you were
promised they were never there I think
most people in this country recognize
that after 40 years of membership of the
European Union delivering brexit dealing
with how we're going to withdraw from
the EU and what our future relationship
is is not an easy is not an easy
negotiation these are complex issues I
think what most members of the public
want those actually who voted for leave
and those many and many of those who
voted for remain as well is for the
government to get on with it that's
exactly what we're doing and for the
government to deliver a deal that is in
the national interest that is going to
protect their jobs and that is going to
ensure that we have a great future of
this country and that's exactly what
we're doing
yes McFarland ABC News I'm Prime
Minister what would you say to Britain's
friends and allies abroad who are
watching all this happening and
witnessing what's increasingly looking
like a government in chaos I think what
people in Brussels will be seeing is
that the government has agreed
the withdrawal agreement they've
recognized and the draft political
outline political declaration they have
recognized that by the fact that
president Janka has written to the EU
Council to president us to say that
decisive progress has been made in the
negotiations and on that basis a council
has been called for the 25th of November
and I think they see a government that
is intent on working with them to ensure
that we deliver a good deal for the
British people but as I've always said I
think a good deal for the UK is a good
deal for the EU as well
Robert Prime Minister you've said that
your deal is in the national interest
but your party is deeply divided on it
perhaps more divided than any of us have
ever seen are you prepared to risk the
breakup of your party to deliver the
deal you believe in as I've just said
Robert an answer to an earlier question
MPs have been debating how best to
deliver on the result of the referendum
ever since the result of the referendum
took place I think what the British
people want us to do and I believe what
MPs will do when it comes to the vote in
the House of Commons is focus on the
fact that people have voted to leave and
and focus on how we do that in a way
that is good for the United Kingdom this
I'm committed as Prime Minister to
bringing the best deal back for the
United Kingdom that's what I'm going to
be doing and I expect when we come that
pub that members of parliament across my
party will look at that deal will
recognise the importance of delivering
on the vote of the British people and
recognise the importance of doing that
in a way that does protect people's jobs
that does protect our security and does
protect our United Kingdom George Gordon
right now from The Telegraph sorry sorry
Prime Minister yeah there are there a
reports tonight that Michael Gove has
been asked to become the new brexit
secretary but that he will only take
that job on condition that he is allowed
to go back to Brussels and try
for more concessions will you allow
whoever becomes the new brexit secretary
to do that to try and get more
concessions and there been no
announcements yet on any appointments to
replace people who resigned are you
struggling to find people who want to
fill those roles no I've had actually
rather a busy day as you might have you
might have seen three hours in the House
of Commons but seriously Michael has
been doing an excellent job at Defra and
particularly in his defence of the
fishing industry and as you'll see
there's some very important elements of
the outline political declaration which
recognize that the United Kingdom will
be an independent coastal state in the
future fishing is an issue that matters
to people and Michael's been doing an
excellent job in terms of ensuring that
we're delivering on that commitment that
we have to come out of the Common
Fisheries Policy I haven't appointed a
new deck sous secretary yet and I will
of course be making appointments to the
government in due course Jason thank you
chasing ghosts in the Daily Mail just
follow up Tom's question we've seen
several of your colleagues today declare
they no longer have confidence in your
leadership what will you do if there's a
vote of no-confidence in the coming days
as I said earlier leadership is about
making the right decisions not taking
the easy decisions as Prime Minister my
job is to get the best deal for Britain
and to bring that deal back to the House
of Commons and that's exactly what I am
focused on doing I think members of the
public want the government to get on
with delivering on brexit for them and
as I said earlier am I going to see this
through yes usually Prime Minister thank
you very much Nick Robertson from CNN
you've talked about leadership as being
the position of taking hard decisions
the right decisions that some of the
choices have not been easy would you
share with the country now some of those
decisions that you personally have found
have been they're hard tough not easy
decisions to take well in relation to
the deal that we're looking at
there's as I've said before I recognize
there are concerns about the backstop
that is an issue and I share many of
those concerns and the decision to go
forward and the basis that we have was
not overall was not an easy one there
was a very good and impassioned debate
that took place in the cabinet yesterday
over these issues but overall looking at
the national interest
we agreed as a cabinet and as a
government that the deal that we have is
the right one to proceed with to go to
the next stage of the negotiations and
obviously those negotiations will lead
up to the EU Council on the 25th of
November the Mesa Thank You Prime
Minister Mesa Hall from The Daily
Express ever since you've been in this
job you've always been adamant that the
country will leave the EU on in March
next year over the last couple of days
you've talked about the risk of no
brexit do you think given the forces
that are lined up in opposition to your
deal that that is now becoming a
definite threat
well I've there were a number of members
of parliament who stood up in the House
of Commons today and and said that their
view was that staying within the
European Union was the right thing to do
I disagree we gave the vote to the
British people Pollin overwhelmingly
gave that vote to the British people to
decide whether or not to stay in the
European Union the people voted to leave
and I believe it is our duty as a
government in believe it's our duty as
members of parliament to deliver on that
vote of the British people and we will
be leaving on the 29th of March 2019 on
the edge there sorry yes I Thank You
Minister Matthew Thompson from LBC I'm
just wearing to what extent this crisis
is to some extent of your own making in
the sense it's a failure of expectation
management and not bringing people out
the DUP and hardliners within your own
party along with you obviously they
weren't going to like what was in this
deal should you not have brought them on
board a little bit more quickly we have
been working on this deal in negotiation
on this deal have been various staging
posts where we've made clear to people
what the the approach that we're taking
to these issues that happened in
December at the joint report obviously
then there was further information that
we put forward in the spring and then in
July our approach was clearly set out
for people we have of course been
discussing with colleagues and with
people in the House of Commons as we
have been discussing with business and
others as we progress through in putting
this deal together what is the focus
what has been the focus as I said
earlier is making sure that the deal
that we deliver is a deal that delivers
on the vote of the British people that
does so in a way which is in the best
national interest which ensures that we
protect people's jobs and livelihood and
security but also ensures that we are
able to move forward outside the
European Union as a global Britain and
for example to ensure that we can
negotiate trade deals around the rest of
the world I believe that's what's in the
interests of people here in this country
and that's what we will deliver I'll
take a couple more questions
lots of reporters anybody who thinks
I've got George Parker on my mind it's
lots of reporters with no hair Prime
Minister I think that's it
Prime Minister if if the House of
Commons voted by a majority for another
referendum for a people's vote would you
see that as a resignation matter or do
you see that as you having to implement
the will of Parliament as Prime Minister
oh no I have taken a very clear view
about the question of a second
referendum I've made that view clear to
members of parliament and I think
actually across the House of Commons
most members of parliament recognise
that they gave a vote to the British
people and the British people voted and
it's up to us to deliver on that vote
and not have a second referendum as far
as I'm concerned that will not be a
second referendum we ask people their
view they said we should leave the
European Union and we will leave the
European Union and we will leave on the
29th of March 2019 look if we look
across the House of Commons yes there
have been some voice those voices for a
second referendum but I believe actually
when people come to look at the deal
that we bring back from the European
Council the final package
that we bring back from the European
Council they will look at delivering on
the vote of the British people and at
doing so in a way that protects the
interests of their constituents and I
believe that is the question that
members of parliament will be asking
themselves at that point not about a
second referendum I'll take as I said
just a couple more just in that hi I'm
Hanna allotment from BuzzFeed news and
my question is given the difficulty
you're likely to have getting this deal
through Parliament do you regret calling
a general election last year no I don't
regret calling a general election last
year as I say you know when it comes to
the vote in Parliament there will be a
decision for MPs to take I'm going to do
my job I'm going to bring the best deal
back for the British people and MPs will
then there do then do their job and of
course be held to account by their
constituents for it so the last question
here Thank You Jo what's the independent
prime minister you're a cricket fan from
the outside it looks like at the moment
you're a long long way off getting the
number of runs that you need but your
batsmen are dropping like flies
it's there any number of wickets that
will fall in your cabinet before you
resign as captain
well can I can I just say that you might
you might recall from previous comments
I've made about cricket that one of my
cricket heroes was always Geoffrey
Boycott and what did you know about
Geoffrey Boycott Geoffrey Boycott stuck
to it and he got the runs in the end
thank you